do not hide the deep emotion
entering this European parliament
after having seen at the entrance the
flags and colored flags of many states
joined together in the European parliament
where we talk we discuss we look into each other's
eyes it was not always like this and the
day of 27  January is a
day that is sometimes repeated too often
considered to be the same thing that is still spoken about
January 27, giving to January 27
an importance that is not really that
Auschwitz had been freed that day
the Red Army entered and it is very good
for the description he makes  first rise in the
truce of these four Russian soldiers
who open and find themselves in front without
releasing anything because the Nazis had
already escaped for so many days they
are faced with this incredible spectacle
at the moment in their eyes then later
much later it became an
incredible spectacle for  who wants to look at it
someone wants to look at it even
now says that it is not true but on January 27th
I was 13 years old  i and I was a
slave worker in the ammunition
factory union factory which is still there and where
we made machine gun shells all of a
sudden in the factory after we had
heard distant explosions because she worked
in the city of auschwitz and we felt and
knew that things were
happening  a real mischievous knot had been
until very recently and the immediate command came
from the factory itself to
start what was called
the death march because I was not
freed on January 27 by the
red
army I was part of that group of more than
50  thousand prisoners still alive and who
had been forced in those
physical conditions without talking about
what the psychic ones were to start
that march that lasted months and of which
very little is talked about the death march and
that when I speak in schools as a
grandmother like  I have been speaking as a grandmother for thirty years now
I say that everyone owes one
leg in front of the other in life
never lean on anyone because  hé in
the death march we could not
lean on the
neighbor who was dragging himself on the snow with
wounded feet like us and who was
finished by the guards of the escort if he
was killed no one could
stay there on those side streets but
how to do it
how to do it in  those conditions because
the strength of life is extraordinary and
this that must be transmitted to
today's young people who are mortified
by the lack of work mortified by the
vices they receive from their
soft parents for which everything is allowed
while life is not like that, then life
prepares you  to this march that must
become the march for life and we did not
want to die we were madly
attached to life
from whatever was the evil of others
that we were young but and we looked
old without sex without age without breasts
without menstruation without panties we
must not be afraid  of these words because this
is how you take away the dignity of a
woman and you get used to it  now
to survive because there was something
inside us that told us
forward forward forward forward forward and
day after day field after field I
found myself in the fi at the end
of April 1945 think in that
situation how far the 27th of
January was a wounded girl was a
wild girl and a girl who no
longer knew how to eat the knife with a fork
because I was still used to
fre stand il the stand which meant
how beasts that eat frechette
is not stand and as such I was bulimic and
as such
I was also disgusting and as such
I was criticized even by those who
loved me wanted the
bourgeois girl again with the good family education it
is difficult to remember these
things for 75 years an absolutely
incredible period while all the past has
meant that the peoples
sometimes they didn't know each other and the
flags and flags outside that
I remembered at the beginning made me
remember the right one  iderio of
finding with the Dutch
with the French with the Poles with the
Germans with the Hungarians a
common word for example of the Hungarian
learned a single word that was bread
kenner unhappy in Hungarian and is the
main word here it means hungry but
what does it mean  also the sacredness of
something that is wasted
today without even looking at what is
thrown away then I for three years at least
feel that the memories of that little
girl I was while today I am a
90 years old do not give me peace do
not give me peace because  since
I became a grandmother 30 years ago 32 years ago
of my grandson
one of my three grandsons luckily I
have three as well as three wonderful children
and what a European parliament and not my
extinction
seem to me at this moment the same
miracle I don't know if  I am wrong
therefore even today I struggle to remember but
it seemed to me a great duty to accept
this invitation and to have this opportunity
to remember the evil of others but also
to remember what  he one leg
in front of the other can be like that
little girl from the rising that whoever will go to
prague or has already been there and visited the
museum of children who in teresi in
could make plays or color with
crayons and that then a  day were
all the deportees killed in auschwitz
for the guilt of ser born born because they
were children so they could not have
hurt anyone
there is a little girl whose name I do not
remember who drew a
yellow butterfly flying over the barbed wire
I did not have colored pencils and perhaps they
had never had the
wonderful fantasy of the little girl of the rising
that the yellow butterfly always
flies over the barbed wires and this is a very
simple message that I
would like to leave to my future
ideal grandchildren who are in  able to make the
choice and with their responsibility and
their conscience always be that
yellow butterfly that flies over the barbed wire
[Applause]
[Music]